thank you for coming and so today I'll
be talking through how we've been
combining computer vision and natural
language processing for multitask
fashion attribute modeling at shop
runner so first off what a shop owner
and shop earner is a american-based
ecommerce company and we essentially
partner with around 140 retailers which
represent thousands of individual brands
historically the core business offering
for shop earner has been this kind of
two-day free shipping and returns
yes very much like Amazon Prime and what
more recently we have been starting to
develop out more data products and
offerings to help expand our partner
retailer capabilities so at shop runner
we have kind of very specific definition
of attributes as I'm sure most
organizations do so for us an attribute
is a characteristic for product which
can be applied across multiple taxonomy
categories so taxonomy categories are
things like that you would find in
different sections of a department store
so things like women's shoes and men's
shoes on the other hand we have taxonomy
cat or actually categories which are
things like color and patterns so these
are things that can be applied across
those various categories and on the
right-hand side here I have kind of a
sample attribute feed that I generated
with my models essentially these were
parts of presentations to internal
product managers at shop owner with the
idea that sometimes saying oh this model
has a macro macro precision of 0.94 or
an F data score of 0.9 with a beta of
0.3 is not really the best way to convey
things to non non-technical types of
folks so what they care about at the end
of the day is really how clean of feeds
are like how I guess clean the product
catalog we look when you filter or
search by different things so this is an
example of like black and solid so at
stop corner it's important that we be
able to standardize are essentially the
attributes across our entire product
catalog because retailers can report
things in whatever way shape or form
that they choose so we might have one
retailer with reports very generic
colors so black white blue red etc but
another one that might take a very
different more artsy approach and say oh
this is obsidian irie cream midnight
blue dusk roads etc and so we need to be
able to sort of standardize our millions
of products in our product catalog the
second use case we have for these
attribute models is actually as future
extractors
for other products or sort of things
will be building out either now or in
the future such as visual similarity or
search so this presentation is roughly
gonna follow the data science team at
shop runners sort of development
trajectory for attribute modeling over
2019 so quarter one was really kind of
our R&D phase where we're looking at
what types of data should we use how
should we structure our models and then
I'll walk you through the process of
kind of the architecture as we build out
the component image and text models as
well as our overall ensemble quarter two
on the other hand is kind of building on
the successes we have in key one and
saying how can we physically expand the
architectures that we have so as a bit
of framing for this part of the problem
at shop Runner actually modeling is kind
of a never-ending problem where we'll
never be able to sort of have all the
attributes we want build one unified
data set and then kind of do one round
of modeling to kind of solve it and
production-wise it we kind of have to
build things in increments and be able
to keep continuously adding on sections
to our architecture and that's kind of
going to be I'll talk through two
processes one is sort of a process to
add physically add on new attribute
tasks heads that I'm currently calling
my Frank and network process but the
team hasn't actually vetted that name so
we'll see if it sticks and then the
second thing is a process that we built
out to basically do multi task multi
data set training to kind of allow us to
very easily add-on or train those new
task heads q3 on the other hand is just
going to be kind of wrapping up the
presentation and saying what we have
going on to the horizon so a quarter one
so Y images in text so from our point of
view our products may represent in a
variety of ways the two to two main ways
of which are these images and text
fields so images you would say that
every product has multiple images per
listing and they encode certain
attributes well so things like color and
pattern really if your product images on
your ecommerce site are not conveying
these attributes they're really not
doing anything at all and on the other
hand text encodes things like sleeve
length sizing and cuts particularly well
so you could think of a situation where
maybe you're looking at an actually like
neckline but an image of that may
physically physically be occluded so say
the picture is a model from the back
we're trying to determine
finally basically impossible with that
but the text will usually encode that
very well
and since these data sources provide
sort of different perspectives on our
individual products the data science
human shop owner felt that these would
be good candidates for building a larger
neural network ensemble so the other
reason that we have is kind of
interested using both images and text is
because sometimes our data is just bad
in one type or the other so for this one
the image is great it you can see it's a
pair of jeans we can see various
attributes about it but if you look at
the text we have a very weird series of
symbols that have been inserted into the
product description and that on its own
may be enough to throw off a solely
text-based model but combination of the
two you might go to make it work on the
other hand we have this pair of jeans
where the image is basically useless but
the text is fairly descriptive so for
the image I would think this is okay
maybe this is a handkerchief or
tablecloth or something well I basically
product description it's actually a very
expensive pair of Fendi jeans that I
wouldn't know otherwise so now that I've
kind of talked through sort of different
data sources of interest and why we
think it's good to kind of build these
two and combine them I'm going to talk
to your kind of our technical tool and
choice which is multitask learning and
one of the most fun and interesting ways
I've seen it described is actually using
a pop culture reference we had Karate
Kid so in the movie Karate Kid if you're
trying to think of exploring this
problem the problem domain of karate the
main antagonist are these sort of very
bullish looking folks on the Left called
the Cobra Kai essentially in the movie
in the movie Karate Kid they learn
karate as a way to beat people up so
they're exploring the domain of karate
with this very narrow hypothesis but on
the other hand we have the karate kid
who learns to do karate from a man named
mr. Miyagi
when mr. Miyagi teaches him karate he
doesn't actually teach him how to fight
how to punch how to kick what he teaches
him is a series of seemingly unrelated
tasks so things like waxing a car
painting a fence sanding a walkway and
while these things don't appear to be
directly related to the overall problem
domain of karate what these sort of
shared context and lessons by learning
these tasks help the karate kid don't
over reach a better understanding of
karate as a whole rather than how the
kubrik island has a way to fight the
card a kid learns it's sort of as a more
generalized version of karate that
includes sort of
respect compassion discipline is really
a way of life so a chopped runner what
we care about is being able to build
these models would you generalize well
and have a good generalized
understanding of our fashion problem
domain so in explicit machine learning
terms multitask learning acts as a form
of regularization in the network so you
can see it as a network that is trained
in a multitask manner and tries to
specialize in to a specific task it
actually gets explicitly punished by the
loss function in training so that it
basically must learn a more generalized
representation of the problem of domain
in order to do well so for us we have
specific attributes like pattern style
and color and these all these all fall
in our fashion domain and basically we
think that by and sharing context across
these tasks and kind of letting each of
them learn together with one another we
can create these good generalizable
robust models that we can put into
production with confidence so now I've
talked through kind of the background
for multi-class learning I didn't walk
to you sort of example architecture and
what you'd do a trapper there's a form
of multitask learning where it's called
hard parameter sharing so in this type
of multitask learning that basically
each each task shares maybe 99.9% of the
features or weights in the network so
this core model could be anything really
like a CNN lsdm any network that you
want to train to a particular domain
then you pipe these features into a
series of linear tasks heads then in
training what happened is did you feed a
sampler batch through the core model the
task heads output their probabilities or
scores and they generally you can
generate these losses per per individual
task then what you have to do is combine
them into some sort of unified batch
loss then you can use for back
propagation and while this sounds
complicated or potentially hard really
what you end up doing is you end up
adding these things together so it's
actually pretty simple so this is what
we found to be effective at chop burn
and also in like kind of various
research papers we read up to our R&D
period and in the event that one of
these losses starts to get much higher
than another just for a specific task
you can actually scale those losses
accordingly so they're more in line with
one another yeah so now that I've talked
to kind of that general architecture I
want to talk to you kind of our general
training protocol which would be pretty
similar if you've done sort of like
various deep learning things so first
the first thing to do
randomly initialize new layers so
typically for us these are the task
heads that we're trying to add on to our
existing networks you then freeze the
pre-trained sections of the networks and
then then aggressively train the random
linear sly sections with high learning
rates and at this point you'll usually
get those new layers up to a point where
they have like some domain knowledge but
won't be state-of-the-art so really they
push it up to that state-of-the-art
level what you end up doing is
unfreezing the entire network and
training the entire thing at a low
learning rate and there's a couple
different ways to do that so like a very
vanilla way would be just to assign a
low learning rate and train the entire
network but think what other groups
they'll say like faster yeah the kind of
way that they recommend doing this is
assigning sort of a gradient of learning
rates throughout their network or
something I found to be effective with
these is just to assign different
sections of the network different
learning rates different depending on
like how pre-trained that section is so
now I've talked through the general
stuff we're just gonna dive into the
architectures so our image model
architecture starts out with two inputs
so right now we're using a full product
image and then a center crop of that
original product image so I'll get into
that sort of next couple slides but both
of these are fed one by one to a coronet
fifty-fifth resident 50 model and this
is essentially a resident 50 model that
we've kind of fine-tuned to the specific
fashion domain and what we do here is we
take the penultimate layer of that
resident 50 which is a vector of 2048
and we essentially concatenate these
together to make a combined vector of
4096 and that combined vector is
something that we feed through a dense
network so here the dense number that
dense number is really trying to kind of
condense these features down to
something more digestible for our linear
task layers and that kind of is the
general structure for our custom CNN
architecture so the interesting part of
that was really that we decided to use
this full image and the center crop of
that original image as inputs into this
network and it was kind of driven by
discussions of brainstorming our data
science team had very early on in this
process
where we're thinking that you actually
get product images from our retailers
and fairly large room very like high
resolution like two thousand or 2,000
pixels for instance and resizing it down
to 224 by 224 actually represents a very
significant amount of detailed context
loss for that image for that network so
our thought was if we can find a way to
kind of react some detail context
information into the network we'll be
able to perform well on specific
attributes which require that kind of
detailed information so the the reason
that we ended up doing this was actually
not because of anything I do data
science related well it's actually kind
of a previous career I had as a
photographer so in photography very
early on you you're kind of
indoctrinated with certain ways to
compose photos so a very basic thing you
do is called the rule of thirds and it's
essentially the idea that you place
image you place the points of interest
in an image on either the vertical or
horizontal lines or on the intersections
of those lines but what happens when you
pair that kind of I guess indoctrination
for a composition and the fashion domain
is that when you look at these
tic-tac-toe boards at center square
they're really that Center crop gives
you a good center of mass shot or detail
of that given product and that happens
for most of our cases and what happens
when we add that sort of context
injection into the network is we get a
couple percentage points over just using
our vanilla base image model but the
downside here is very much that we if
our retailer shoot in a way that doesn't
conform to that standard we get Center
crops which actually aren't that useful
so like this one we get mostly
background part of the spirit part of
the hand so not the best center crop and
not the best context into the network so
something that our team has been
building out in parallel has been doing
things like quilting detection so
building in house clothing model is
basically tailored to our fashion domain
with the idea we can take these bounding
boxes and actually use that as a
pre-processing step before the actually
model so that if we take a center crop
of that we're basically guaranteed to
get a good center of mass shot of that
product then in parallel something else
something else we're doing is doing sort
of clothing segmentation so the idea
that rather than if we can do something
better than just returning that area of
the picture and just return like the
pixels related to a given product in an
image we can actually run that over our
entire product catalog and say
standardize it for usage and other deep
learning models so it would be just the
product on a purely
white background so it'd be very clean
standard image to pass into other deep
learning models so now that I've talked
to kind of our image architecture and
some stuff that we're doing there I'll
get into the I guess NLP section and
really it's leveraging Google's Bert and
I'll talk through sort of the details of
bird in a couple slides but first trying
to go through the architecture so
architecture starts out we the fields
that we're using are things our product
name description brand other info
specialty sizing etc and we take that
feed that into a core Bert model that
has been fine-tuned to our fashion
domain and then really we just take
those features and pipe them into a
series of linear tasks heads so this is
a very fairly simple architecture but
this is kind of what folks are using in
the NLP field to get state of the art
results on NLP tasks so there's a group
at Microsoft Word published a paper and
nicknamed their model Big Bird kind of
adding on to the questionable Sesame
Street naming all these NLP models but
essentially what they did is they found
that they could get state-of-the-art
results on NLP tasks simply by training
Bert in a multitask fashion because in
comparison to like bass bird which held
the previous benchmarks the multitask
version is forced to find out more
generalized representation of those
different problems and then generalizes
better to the actual task so we're
basically just copying what they have
been doing so Bert is a model that was
released at the end of 2018 by Google
and it is a bi-directional model that
has been trained to predict out master
words and sentences so this is a little
bit different from a lot of the other
language models that have been released
in the past year and so what I mean
there is like most languages are trained
as here's some section of context and
then you generate the right next word in
the sentence is kind of how they're
trained but what Bert does is it's
actually given the full sentence as
context certain words in that sentence
are then masked out with some
probability and then Bert uses both the
left and right side of the sentence
around that master word to predict the
master outward and we will kind of found
that to be very effective training
regimen for their algorithm and like
other like other language models birds
trained on a large corpus of data so in
this case all the poppy dia and whatever
other corpus as Google felt like
including and really it and the other
language models that have been released
in the past year facilitating this very
interesting imagenet moment for NLP
or it's actually quite exciting to be
part of the field because previously
it's been hard to sort of apply
state-of-the-art NLP models to specific
problem domains because most people have
lessened data than Google which is not
surprising at all so what happens when
people when Google and other
organizations open-source these large
language models it means you can take
these models which have a very rich
understanding of language and apply them
to specific problem domains and get
state-of-the-art results very quickly so
it's sort of this democratization of NLP
so it's a fun time to be in the field so
in particular we are using a open-source
version of Bert which is maintained by a
group called hugging face so yet another
kind of interesting name but what if
they have done is they brought the
Google Google tensorflow in BO to
implementation of Bert into the pite
work sort of environment and they've
allowed for loading loading and saving
models that much like other high torques
models they've included tokenizer
classes which allow you to pre process
inputs and get them into the correct
format for of the Bert based on its
vocab and you can really integrate it
very straightforwardly into a very
standard PI towards pipeline so it makes
it easy to add on to your sort of
existing deep learning work that you or
your company are doing so if you're
looking for a way to kind of crack some
NOP problems I think definitely suggest
take a look at this so now that I've
talked to you sort of our component
models I'll dive into a little bit about
our ensemble so the ensemble really we
start out with the various inputs for
the two models that I have talked to you
already so it's a full image cropped
image and the various text fields we
then take our pre trained models so
these are the models that have been
trained to our fashion domain so the
image model text model and really using
this feature extractors in this ensemble
so we take the features out of those two
models concatenate them together and
then feed them through another dense
Network where this dense network is once
again trying to sort of condense these
features before they're passed directly
into the linear task heads and what we
found by doing building us ensemble kind
of training both the models and to end
and then letting them adjust their
weights very gradually is we get like
another couple percentage point and
provement over either of either of the
core models individually so like while
they both perform well they both have
their strengths and weaknesses for
certain attribute types so combining
them together it kind of lets us make
the best of those strengths and
weaknesses and we're able to get a
fairly usable and practical I guess deep
end-to-end deep learning ensemble so
this is kind of like the end of the
quarter one stuff and we've basically
shown that we can build these build
these networks combine them and get good
results so in quarter two we're really
looking at how do we physically expand
these architectures to kind of meet this
never-ending attribute problem that shop
runner so in expanding the number of
categories there's really two problems
that we had so the first problem we ran
into is we have these previous
architectures and how do we physically
expand them to include new task heads
without throwing away to pre train
weights because if you do this and
basically try and take a 1 architecture
and force-feed it into another fight or
two or three errors or in the worst case
scenario actually appear to work but if
you aren't careful about it you actually
get predictions that are different or
evaluation metrics that have changed
from your previous iteration of the
model so if you're not very cognizant
about that you'll actually get models
that you think are working but are
actually terrible and it's quite scary
so once you can figure out how to add on
as a new task heads you can our the next
one was basically how to train them and
while we have like very traditional
methods which are based around having a
single data set mark with all of our
classes our team at shop one was
basically wondering is there a better
way that we can do that and then if
that's like our main objective are kind
of like side mission side quest is to
keep our model countdown with the idea
that one maintaining lots of models is
hard and places a lot a lot of extra
burden on our team since our team is
responsible for deploying monitoring and
kind of maintaining these models but
also because if we start building sort
of new models to fit new attribute
categories well that's easy from kind of
a modeling point of view it means that
we lose out on a lot of the multitasking
goodness that I talked to you about
previously so now I'm going to talk to
you about sort of this like Franken
model or process that we use to add on
new task heads so first step is really
just a load up that pre train
architecture so this is the one this is
like the previous round of modeling
where you've basically production eyes
vetted the model seeing off task one two
and three I'll perform fairly well but
now you have to go ahead and add a new
so what you end up doing is you
initialize this random kind of shell of
an architecture so it has all the core
components so core model task 1 task
each a story and you're really just
adding all that task 4 and what you end
up doing is sliced you end up slicing
apart this old pre-trained model so you
load it up
slice it into its like little pieces of
a component structure and then once you
do that and you start sliding it into
the husk of an architecture so core
model goes there task 1 2 & 3 get put in
the respective places and since these
are kind of putting weights into a new
architecture and the 4 Passons
architecture has already been defined if
you pass the data through this new like
populated Shelvin architecture you
actually get the task 1 task 2 you
testily performing at the levels that
they were before and now that task 4 is
just the only randomly intersection you
have to worry about so now when you're
at this point you can actually go ahead
and train that new task 4 in whatever
way you see fit so like if you followed
our previous regimen you end up freezing
all the other tasks on the core model
training it aggressively at a higher
learning rate I want to say it's not a
good point you get on the freeze
everything train at a low learning rate
and the end result is you get this model
that can now do all four tasks at once
rather than just three and the process I
laid out there is actually very so it
works very well from like a data science
point of view but from a business point
of view it's actually slightly
suboptimal so from a business point of
view because we're adjusting the weights
in the rest of the network we're kind of
creating a completely new model from the
one that we had before even if those
metrics are very similar to what they
what they were originally so right now
that's kind of the process that our team
goes through and we have to end it we
end up having to read that most of the
model so in an ideal world we'd be able
to train it and basically only train the
weights for a new section but that's
kind of an ongoing piece of work that
the team has so now that we can
physically add on those task heads I
just want to go through kind of a what
the training training regimen that we
built out for it is and really the
classic way to approach this problem is
you have this one data set to rule them
all you have one data set that's marked
with all your categories and you build
one model you train it let's go and you
can production-wise it and you're
basically good to go
but for us because we keep incrementing
having to add on these certain
categories if we maintain
large data set and then basically add on
any category we are we don't have that
guarantee that that new parent category
will be well represented in our original
data set so we run the risk of a
situation where we add on a new category
and certain classes are basically
non-existent so then we have to go
through get a new data set label that
completely with both the old and new
labels unify them and basically keep
maintaining things in that way so this
is kind of a very arduous very kind of
expensive process so something that the
team thought would be interesting would
be can we train these multitask models
with data sets tailored for each task
rather than just one data set that has
all the tasks contained within it and
really the idea here is that if we can
do that multi data set training we can
build data sets with whatever way makes
the most sense for that particular
category so for instance maybe we have a
previous round of work that was done
where folks went ahead and labeled a
section of our product catalog with a
certain set of categories that we might
be able use as an attribute so it
becomes a very low effort way to build
that category whereas other ones we
might have to build out manually label
data sets with like figure 8 or tasks or
figure eight a Mechanical Turk so those
things we can do but we don't have to do
it over an entire like 7 million product
catalog because I found extremely
expensive so this process that we built
out is well it took us a good bit of
like R&D trying to fiddle with it to try
and get it to try and get it to actually
work well but I think once you figured
it out it's actually fairly intuitive so
I hope you guys think so as well so when
we start we have the same we are doing a
three tasks problem and we have three
data sets of color pattern style we can
basically go ahead and pre process and
prepare these things we load it with
whatever way makes the most sense or
whatever makes the most sense for their
framework that you're using so building
your data loaders or data generators
respectively once these are built you
can basically shuffle the batches
randomly so you kind of what we're doing
here is creating this kind of grab bag
of batches that will then start to
randomly sample without replacement and
what happens so in this case we draw a
square which is a color batch so we take
the color batch and feed it into the
core model and the core model is
actually we're gonna let it output the
probabilities and scores for each of the
three problems
what we're gonna do is only calculate
the loss for color because this is a
color batch and actually only color is
marked in this data set so then what we
do is we use that color loss for that
propagation for the specific iteration
in this epoch so in the second iteration
or other iterations so you pick a circle
which is a pattern batch we take me take
that pattern batch feed it through the
network and we let it output the
probabilities for a color pattern and
style but we just calculate the pattern
loss and use that for back propagation
so then basically the training epoch
ends when we sample the last batch feed
that through and use that specific
batches loss for back propagation so the
end result of this is that you you get a
model or a multitask network that when
you feed a sample through can now
actually do very I guess reasonable
strong predictions for all of these
categories although it's never actually
seen a sample that has been marked with
all three of these categories so for us
this quarter was kind of a fun
successful one because we were able to
build out these cheap processes and then
with it were able to physically expand
and sort of expand a new category and
continue to perform perform well on the
categories we don't actually built
previously so then kind of quick
wrapping up and the I guess going
forward so quarter one we really
demonstrated that these multitask
fashion like attribute models are
feasible to build in a I guess full
neural network ensemble type way then in
quarter two we sort of showed that we
can expand these architectures and we
can expand them so do new categories
which is sort of a core component of our
actually modeling problem at shop runner
then in quarter three we're really what
we're really looking to continue to
deploy improve versions of our models so
certain categories that we built there's
some weak classes so we actually want to
go through and augment those sections of
those data sets with ways that make
sense we're gonna continue to use these
methods to build out new categories so
like I said it never ends so we'll keep
well we will keep on marching along then
having solved some of the I guess back
in infrastructure type problems mostly
around shop run are not having hosts of
these gigantic neural network ensembles
and our flask API endpoints before so
now we're at a point where we think we
can deploy them and not actually crash
our company servers which is good and
basically since these attribute models
are now at these sort of very strong
points we want to start using them as
feature extractors or as components of
other pipelines so like visual
similarity and search style
personalizations for our users and
things like outfitting which are kind of
very orangey things that our company is
working on so that's not you all I have
and questions oh and as a quick note
this is a this is our team's unofficial
team logo it's basically when I
basically when I joined ups we were
looking to change it from our pygmy goat
logo to something else so I suggested
the horse that engine name drew during
his deep learning AI course but our
director shut it down because he really
likes pugs and wanted a pug
so obviously put Photoshop a pug onto a
nanny approved it so yeah thank you very
much for the talk
it's very nice to see Burt in the wild I
want ask two questions first one when
you train the model is is quite large
model like Burt itself to train if you
train in 10 birthdays resonates what
kind of put back ended use for training
the second question for scaling up I'm
not asking about flask AAP ice is more
like how you justify the cost of running
those models on it like GPU or TPU
instances and like how much do you like
like manage the revenue from those
models yeah okay cool so in represent
the first question around sort of the
backend and scaling how we train it
we're actually training on AWS instances
so most of them are being trained on you
think p3 instances either the PTO or p8
or 16 forego the larger ones are called
but for now we're mostly doing single
GPU training I think at a point where
the models get larger we'll probably
ought to start doing the larger
instances with multi GPS and some
parallel parallelism but for right now
the models can be fairly comfortably
trained in a reasonable amount of time
on those single like I guess p3
instances AWS and then reference to sort
of how we're scaling it the what we end
up doing is we take the models and kind
of do one so the first thing we have to
do is really like label are a huge
existing product catalog so that's kind
of a big one time
for us then after that we're kind of
doing smaller incremental updates so for
us we're fine running these services on
CPUs so it's not actually as expensive
as if we were hosting them on like P 3
instances or something so we basically
have that one large computing section
where we kind of get the entire product
catalog up to date and then we're just
doing daily batches essentially to get
new things so for them like the last bit
where you have three different
categories of
data sets that you're trying to predict
color pattern style then for the final
loss I not sure I get why you have to
separate like for each batch you have a
you separate out like only one loss at I
myself just adding them together like
what you did before
yeah so I've done both I've done in
versions of both but essentially if you
have the sort of adding the adding the
losses together and so you take a like
pattern law or pattern batch color batch
and style batch and kind of feed them
through added loss together and deep
back propagation you have to be New York
you have to like reduce the batch sizes
down so actually comes quite look quite
a bit slower to do the training so
rather than kind of feeding the one but
one batch through which is much larger
do the single we're still around a
backpropagation it's kind of a speed
trade-off and we found in doing the
guest training cycle Hey so we're
working on similar problems at stitch
fix and one thing that we have had
trouble with is with outfits if you have
like a jacket over a shirt how do you
get this shirt um have you yet come up
with tips for that hmm yeah so that's
one that we've also run into given that
very like in that very similar domain so
that would kind of be you might have to
build very specialized like segmentation
models that are basically tailored just
to give that type of outfit so that's
kind of my thought on it currently but
we haven't really did like Dogen to that
very deeply we have a lot of other other
initial things to figure out first
and for this a scale of this computation
you have a three data size use the
industry data size roughly how big are
they each them when you do the train for
the training yeah so each a sex like
hundreds of two hundred thousand
products essentially or so they're not
like super huge we're not using like all
of all of our existing product catalog
we're basically using sections that we
have existing labels for or something
analogous enough to allow us to train
quickly and then we're basically going
through and if they're certain certain
sections of those data sets which are
messy or not clean enough for our usage
they were basically trying to figure out
ways to go back and add on additional
samples to those sections but yeah for
now it's a hundred to two hundred
thousand things per data set anybody
else
you're regarding the use of birds and
weddings and did you try more simpler
and weddings being compared to avert in
order to get how how much the game is
because in our case the training of of
birth that takes quite a lot of
resources we abandoned it for the time
being waiting for new more efficient
techniques we use tf-idf and it's
working moral as well and do you have
done the comparison with another secret
methods so we haven't done it for
attribute modeling but for basically
another set of deep learning that we
were doing with fertilize our taxonomy
categorizations we were practicing or
trying to do initially with tf-idf
matrixes but we were having sort of
going to computational issues with the
ways that we had built those pipelines
basically like the large number of
categories in large large amount of data
we're trying to run into bottlenecks in
training so then that team kind of
switched over using OMPH it would be
like faster higher area in Beart so we
kind of built out these pipelines and
the ways to Train it when we're doing
the taxonomy classification work so then
when you started to actually model my
work we kind of just pipe that over
since it was basically
analogous from our pipeline side so we
haven't done it for explicitly for how
to be modeling anybody else okay cool
let's give them a round of applause
please
[Applause]